d
Splash, du 26 juin au 4 juillet
prochain. Louis de Belleval.
- Il y a du "plutôt réussi"
en matière d'accès à la baignade
dans les eaux du fleuve
à Montréal.
Et aussi de l'inachevé.
Mais surtout,
il n'y en a pas beaucoup.
ROY DUPUIS, cofondateur,
Fondation Rivières
- Présentement, à Montréal,
il paraît qu'il y a 170 km de
rive et qu'il y en a seulement
50 qui sont accessibles,
puis elles sont quand même
assez loin.
- Sur ces 50 kilomètres
de berges publiques, quelques
centaines de mètres seulement
sont aménagées pour la baignade.
À la plage urbaine de Verdun,
au parc naturel du Cap-Saint-
Jacques ainsi qu'au parc
Jean-Drapeau, des milliers
de baigneurs profitent
des installations.
Ceux qui souhaitent
en faire autant au parc de
la Promenade-Bellerive le font
à leurs risques et périls.
YOLAND BERGERON, résident
du secteur Tétreaultville
- C'est pas tous les endroits
qui sont faciles d'accès.
Il y a beaucoup de roches,
beaucoup d'érosion.
Donc, les aménagements qui
avaient été faits à l'époque
ont comme été détruits.
On pourrait aller faire un tour
tantôt; tu vas voir les gros
rochers qui ont comme déboulé.
- Yoland Bergeron et
l'architecte-paysagiste
Daniel Chartier militent
depuis des décennies
pour compléter le travail.
DANIEL CHARTIER
architecte-paysagiste
- On voit pas le fleuve!
On devrait voir le fleuve.
Le but principal, c'est
d'avoir un accès visuel
et physique au fleuve.
C'est ça qui devrait être
le but principal de ce parc-là.
- Et le projet de plage
est sur pause.
D'autres projets
sont sur la table.
À Lachine, la mairesse
de l'arrondissement,
Maja Vodanovic,
mise sur la récupération
de l'ancienne marina.
MAJA VODANOVIC, mairesse de
l'arrondissement de Lachine
- Beaucoup comme ça se fait
en Europe sur les rivières
et les lacs urbains.
Alors, des grands quais aménagés
à partir desquels les gens vont
pouvoir sauter, se baigner.
- Le site a l'avantage
de bénéficier d'une eau
propre et profonde.
Le projet fera prochainement
l'objet d'une consultation
publique et pourrait voir
le jour dans cinq ans.
Ici Louis de Belleval,
Radio-Canada, M